whereas I was looking at the statistics
on the show and we not only have
listeners that have been with us on the
radio and podcast and YouTube for many
many years in some cases decades but
we've got a new batch coming in almost
daily mm-hmm the numbers on the podcast
and YouTube's growth and our ratings on
radio are all skyrocketing and so it
occurs to me that occasionally instead
of just answering questions we had us to
stop and go you know we teach some
pretty basic stuff here and yet it
always it was the first time I got hate
mail from somebody saying that I was
crazy and that you shouldn't cut up your
credit cards and that you should you
don't need to live on a budget and
whatever I was kind of tickled because I
thought you know that's just weird I
never thought you would talk about
helping somebody with their money and
you'd get hate mail oh yeah but we can
bail our freaking hate mail around here
I'm gonna use it for kindling in the
winter I mean it comes in by the bushel
and certainly those of you that without
any backbone at all don't sign the
letters of course and we don't answer
hate mail we answer other letters but
and you know and of course digital world
you can you can say anything you want to
say behind an avatar because you're
complete wuss and so people say all
kinds of crazy stuff but what what all
that outlines is not that we're
thin-skinned and we don't that we don't
we don't love criticism but anytime you
stand for something it immediately means
that you stand against something else
that's right you can't it's it's a it's
philosophically theologically impossible
mm-hmm to not pick a fight when you
stand for something right even though
you weren't trying to pick a fight it's
not what you're trying to do but when we
say listen don't be normal normal is
broke 78 percent of Americans live
paycheck to paycheck you always talk
about driving down your street right
that's right and you can see this Dave
and and you think about it you know when
I first joined have two haven't been in
in the in the former industry of banking
I was in shocking yeah you come over and
I
would hear you talk about stats but you
talked about him in the way that it was
representing individuals and families
and so when you hear 78 percent of
living paycheck-to-paycheck
I tell people think of ten of your
friends now some people don't have ten
borrow from somebody but but think of
ten that means eight out of the ten of
your friends are living paycheck to
paycheck and you bring it closer to home
you think of ten family members and so
when people on your street anywhere you
go and so in any neighborhood any yes
not just the big houses in any house and
so as I hear that and the teaching got
more and more personal for me because
now when I hear those stats I think of
family members I think of people and so
you know it is here's the thing if you
keep doing what you've been doing yeah
duh you're gonna keep getting what
you've been getting if you plant corn
don't be shocked the corn grows yeah if
you plant nothing don't be shocked that
you have a dirt farm yeah I mean why
would you be shocked but we're always
like you know like we keep MIT using the
same recipe wanting chocolate cake it
always turns out vanilla change the
recipe you know quit doing the stupid
but stuff that gave you mediocre or bad
results in your life and that's what
happened to me I broke and I said this
doesn't work this crap that I've been
taught and that the culture believes
that you borrow your way into prosperity
it's absolutely moronic yeah it's
ridiculous we just get that Dave and you
can you understand no you don't
understand you're an idiot we've got
this figured out when you don't have any
payments it is the shortest path to
wealth hmm why is this hard
no well and you told me what's the
percentage of homes Dave to get
foreclosed on that are paid off zero
yeah we did detail we did research
research and so I think American Express
calls my house it's a wrong number
oh yeah there's no business there no I
don't have American distress no but
here's the thing Dave when you start to
go against the norm people are going to
have opinions people don't have opinions
so listen what we're telling you folks
is this if you're broke friends are
making fun of your new
a financial plan that means you're on
track yeah I mean if five people are
making fun of your diet it means your
own track
you know just seriously think about it
normal is not excellent that's right
normal sucks normal is you live paycheck
to paycheck your whole life and you hope
the government which is well known for
its ability to handle money will take
care of you
that's dumber than a rock it is and Dave
according to this listen to extra 600
people have been getting on unemployment
is running out next month dang dang did
your comfort zone is gone what are you
gonna do the Calvary is not coming out
of Washington DC turns out you are
responsible for you and you can do this
is it easy no Lord no it's not always
fun excellence is never easy yeah yeah
mediocrity is always easy yeah
losing is easy quitting is easy laying
down is easy getting run over is easy
yeah pushing back and saying not me it's
for me in my house we're not doing it
this way yeah
we're gonna save money we're gonna be
outrageously generous we're gonna live
on a plan and if you won't make fun you
ain't bad you can't go out to eat you'll
kiss my butt my kids college funds fund
it it's right I mean really how you like
me now yeah you know you've got to be
more concerned about your future than
you are somebody else's opinion because
I gotta tell you when you're 74 they
gonna be standing there feeding you
they're not gonna protect you and you're
absolutely right and so that was the
power of the what now event that we did
that visceral moment of never again I'm
gonna tell you my social media lit up I
had friends reach out and they say you
know what you Dave and Rachel shook my
cage they said we we said our spouses
together they said we said never again
and it was just this thing and if you
all haven't seen it you need to tap into
it you need to go watch it because it
was America's wake-up call I'm gonna
tell you so when you start getting out
of debt and you're living on a budget
and you're walking the baby steps and
you're building your emergency fund and
you are doing this and you're doing that
there's smart things with money you're
being on your spouse you're
slowing down you're not acting like a
four-year-old on the cereal aisle I
deserve it I'm entitled you're not
entitled you're just a brat you know
that's ridiculous you're entitled to
nothing unless you killed it and drugged
it home that's what you're entitled to
that's it and even then you give half
that to your government for people that
think they are entitled so if you're
doing these things you 100 percent of
the time are going to have people that
don't understand your upcoming success
yes 100% of the time these people are
known as losers and you need to spend
less time with them because losers
always tear down someone else's dream
Davis the crab in the bucket come on
back down here with me stay in here it's
comfy
yeah don't know they don't let the other
crab crawl I don't crawl out you got to
slap them yeah
slap a crab yeah climb you forgot your
upbringing though I didn't you dadgum
right I forgot parts of it it sucks you
know when I left it behind it's right I
left it over there across the tracks you
can keep it I'm grown this is the Dave
Ramsey show